a man
is like a fraction whose numerator
is what he is
and whose denominator
is what he thinks of himself
the larger the denominator
the smaller the fraction
everyone thinks of changing the world
but no one thinks of changing himself
[Music]
all happy families are alike
each unhappy family
is unhappy in its own way
if you look for perfection
you'll never be content
we can know only
that we know nothing
and that is the highest degree of human
wisdom
when you love someone
you love the person as they are
and not as you'd like them to be
only people who are capable of loving
strongly can also suffer great sorrow
but this same necessity of loving serves
to counteract their grief
and heals them
everything
depends on upbringing
if then
i were asked for the most important
advice i could give
that which i considered to be the most
useful to the men of our century
i should simply say
in the name of god
stop a moment
cease your work
look around you
[Music]
if you want to be happy
be
rummaging in our souls
we often dig up something that ought to
have lame there unnoticed
wrong does not cease to be wrong because
the majority share in it
the two most powerful warriors
are patience
and time
the changes in our life must come from
the impossibility to live
otherwise to the demands of our
conscience
not from our mental resolution to try a
new form of life
be bad
but at least don't be a liar
a deceiver
there is no greatness
where there is not simplicity
goodness
and truth
it's much better to do good in a way
that
no one knows anything about it
happiness does not depend on outward
things
but on the way we see them
what counts in making a happy marriage
is not so much how compatible you are
but
how you deal with incompatibility
how can one be well
when one suffers morally
there is no conditions to which a person
cannot grow accustomed
especially if he sees that everyone
around him
lives the same way
a battle is won by him
who is firmly resolved to win it
government
is an association of men who do violence
to the rest of us
debates conceal
rather than reveal the truth
truth is revealed in solitude
if people tell you that you should live
your life preparing for the future
do not believe them
real life is found only in the present
the key to success in life is using the
good thoughts of wise people
money is a new form of slavery
and distinguishable from the old simply
by the fact
that it is impersonal
that there is no human relation between
master and slave
we lost because we told ourselves we
lost
much unhappiness has come from things
left unsaid
upon meeting
you're judged by your clothes
upon parting
you're judged by your wits
to say that you can love one person all
your life is just like saying that one
candle will continue burning as long as
you live
boredom
the desire for desires
there is trouble with the wife but it's
even worse with a woman who is not a
wife
once we're thrown off our habitual paths
we think all is lost
but it's only here
that the new and the good begins
momento mori
remember death
these are important words
if we kept in mind that we will soon
inevitably die
our lives would be completely different
you